usually when someone's limited by fear  they don't know they're limited by fear  so you have to of course look for the  clues what kind of clues do you look for  primary clues is someone who's not  fulfilled  they're not happy and i'm not talking  about gratified  they'll pick up their phone get a  dopamine hit by checking  instagram so they feel gratified but  they  believe they're happy it's like no no  i'm happy people  you know having a vision or a dream of  where they want to be  and them just not going anywhere near  that repeatedly  and then being obedient to authorities  outside of themselves  first and foremost so when someone  outsources their truth  that is a very scared person a brave  person doesn't outsource their truth  listens to their heart their own mind  their own thinking  pays attention to their gut first and  foremost and of course we'll listen to  outside sources  and cut them off when they deserve to be  cut off